[inaudible]
I told you they would.
Tina,
Tina Fey grew up in Pennsylvania.
She spent a lot of time in Chicago,
big fan of second city.
She ultimately became the lead
writer in Saturday night live.
And from there architected one of the
most successful shows on television and
from there had a huge impact in the last
few years on politics and media and so
forth,
and perhaps most important.
She announced last week that she's
pregnant with her second child.
Wow.
They'll Google. Thank you so
much. It's so nice to be here
now.
So I've been reading your book.
I read it and I want to start with a,
with a reading.
Okay.
I hope it's something about
one of my periods are,
yeah,
here's a lot in the
book about women things,
which I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna quote from,
but now every girl is expected to have
Caucasian Blue Eyes, full Spanish lips,
a classic button nose hairless
Asian skin with a California is Tan,
a Jamaican dance hall, ass long,
Swedish legs, small Japanese feats.
The abs have a,
and I'm going to omit the rest.
The person closest to actually
achieving this look as Kim Kardashian,
who as we know was made by Russian
scientist to sabotage our athletes.
Everyone else is struggling.
What does this mean?
This is a, uh, a little section
in the book about the state of,
of being a a woman in 2010.
I was in the book,
I talk about when I grew up
in the seventies and eighties.
You were good looking or not and if you
weren't good looking you could just like
learn a trade and just relaxing and um,
there's this kind of feeling now that
if you are not good luck, good looking,
you are to Frankenstein
yourself until you are,
you are to buy new teeth
and hair and other assets.
And so that's, that's what we're
living with now. Eric, that's a really,
so her, her book is, is wonderful.
It's the funniest book you'll ever read
and it's book not only about her growing
up and all of the things
that happened to her as a,
as a young woman as well as a
professional woman, but a lot about life.
And so it has a lot of
lessons. It. So for example,
stop, I've got a gun, the gun, the gun,
I gave you five wedding anniversary.
Eric, how could you, we're not
married, we're not married.
Is it denial?
We've learned our first improv lesson.
It takes a long time to learn.
This is the,
with an engineer trying to learn it.
It's, it takes a long time, uh, to,
to learn those basic rules of Improv
or why don't you take us through them.
And they were in the bus or they're in
the book because I was an improviser at
second city and at a place called the
Improv Olympic, um, in Chicago. And,
and I talk in the book about Improv
having really kind of changed my
professional life and even sort
of my world view a little bit. Um,
there are some basic rules
of improvisation when you're
creating something out
of nothing. That's the first rule
is to agree, which is to say yes,
which we did do that successfully.
You said freeze. I have a gun and I,
I didn't say that's not a gun.
That's your finger.
Which is what a Google person
would say. Yeah. Okay. Um,
and uh, so we, we agreed and
the next rule is, is yes.
And which is to add on to what
you've already agreed upon.
So the gun, the gun I gave you for our
wedding anniversary, how could you,
and then we hit a brick wall,
Eric.
You know, it's funny cause it's very,
some very famous comedians have,
there's an old story about Joan Rivers
was at the second city briefly in 1959,
1960. And, and they use this
in class at second city.
All the time that there was
someone came in, you know,
so that I want a divorce was the
beginning of the scene. She said,
I want a divorce. And whoever
was with her on stage, she said,
but what about the children? And she
said, we don't have any children,
which in the moment got a big laugh,
which stops, it's killed the scene. Um,
so that's, uh, it's a very, it's a,
my response would be human instincts.
We have children. I just didn't tell
you. That's why we're getting divorced.
Yes. I have some other children. Yes,
this is exactly what, yeah. Okay. Got It.
Hi. For me it was this a
lot about um, being open,
you have to be open to any possibility
and you're being open to the fact that I
did an idea that you stumble upon together
is likely to be more interesting than
the idea that you started
with as individuals.
And I thought all that stuff was very
helpful as a writer. So, so when you,
when you were growing up,
did you,
did you know that you would be
funnier than everybody else? No.
I will tell you this. When you were
13 no, people did not say like,
Oh, you're so funny. I think you, I think
mostly what comedian people in comedy, no,
at a certain age is that they want
to be funny. You know what I mean?
I think that you know that you're really
interested in it and you want to do it
and then you don't know for a long time.
I mean,
I think at 13 year it's manifested itself
as annoying and then you hone it for
like 25 years
and sometimes still annoying.
One of the people who was,
I think the biggest influence on you is,
is Lauren Michaels. And you have in the
book, you have a lot of discussion about,
about Morgan and his rules.
He has a rule for example,
that don't work with people.
You can't hang out with a
three in the morning. Yeah.
Rule, never hire anyone that you don't
want to run into by the bathroom at three
o'clock in the morning.
And he has another rule about
Harvard people and people
who didn't go to college.
Yes. Um, some of these
wheels are, you know,
they're not necessarily some of the things
that he's actually says out loud and
some are things that I just sort of
gathered from spending a lot of time with
him. Um, but he, he's just
somehow knew that there was a, um,
the best mix for Saturday night live.
And to me,
I tried to apply it at 30 rock was
to take a mix of Harvard people,
uh, or Harvard style people. Um,
very cerebral, very organized,
um, well, and then to mix
them with kind of visceral,
um, fun sort of Chicago
people. So you take,
these are two rather broad brushes,
but I've been mixing, you take like I'm,
you know, I'm trying to give hard people,
you went, you take Conan O'brien
and you put him with Chris Farley.
You know what I mean?
And then that is a mix that makes for a
good sketch comedy because when one gets
too cerebral, the other one pulls, you
know, pulls it, pulls it out, and it's,
it actually does work in too much of
one or the other usually is not good.
Yeah. You have another rule. Never
tell a crazy person. He's crazy.
What's prompted that rule?
It just, it, it, it doesn't never
get you, uh, what you, you know,
if someone comes to you
in a workplace situation,
what sort of a strange demand or,
and confused like you,
they've had a problem that you, yourself,
you know, um, don't see as a problem. It,
it's not really useful to say like,
you're being crazy right now.
It doesn't really solve the situation.
Um,
just makes them more upset, which,
yeah, it just makes them not trust you.
And it's something I, cause it's my
instincts that I learned to kind of,
to move away from lists to be like, stop
being crazy. Just everybody, just be cool.
Just really like a good
management technique.
Okay.
We'll try to just be cool.
Everyone does knock it off.
We
now,
I think the most common question that you
get of all is about gender differences
in comedy, comedy writers,
comedy shows and so forth.
And alarmingly in your book, you actually
do say that there's a difference.
I admit to the,
the secret core difference that,
um,
that between male and female comedy
writers usually, you know, I, I try to,
he will ask me that question a lot.
What's the difference between men and
women comedy where they like, and, uh,
usually I try to just be so boring
that they lose interest, um,
in the answer and walk away. Uh, but
because I always say, you know, well,
there's a tremendous amount of overlap
in the middle of what men and women and
all people find funny. And
then at the outset, you know,
men kind of maybe like sharks and
robots doing things more than women.
You know, the masturbating bear, it was
over here and then serve. We're here.
It's like absolutely fabulous, but some
kind of detailed character study things.
Um, but the truth is that, um, the, uh,
the secret truth is that
sometimes the men urinating cups.
Okay.
I don't know if that happens here
first.
I've heard of it if it's true here.
Um, I think it was, and I said certainly
not all of them, but just to see me,
you know,
you compare two zero of them.
Can you imagine the women trying
to do that in their office?
This is really so much fun,
although not impossible.
I think
maybe we should move to this section
of the book.
Also the way the men sometimes pretend
to rape each other and the women never do
that
ideal in generalizations,
but
never do it,
shall we? So we moved to the
next section of the book.
Okay.
What did you want to add anymore?
No, that's it. Okay. Nope.
This book also has a lot of information.
That's very helpful.
As you become enormously
famous and successful and
one of them for yourself was
how to pose.
Yes.
How do be photographed to be
photographed and your photograph,
you've been photographed on everything
and you know, you're now widely,
widely recognized. Can you tell
the story of, as a comedy writer,
nobody knew who you were and now you're
recognized everywhere. Everywhere.
Yeah. It's a weird thing. Um,
and I have actually been photographed
in a lots of kind of formal model like
settings kind of a lot of
times now. And it's, uh,
it is one of the most fun things
you will ever do if you, uh,
people like to pretend to complain about
it and say it's hard. It is delightful.
Um, okay. You are treated too.
You know,
like you're treated like a queen.
You're riding like
anything you want to eat.
Do you want us to some kind
of special coffee or do you,
and it's like so some beautiful
loft space and the um,
and then they try to put
clothes on you that are um,
made for their doll clothes and they,
um, and did you should know that he's,
see anyone you ever see in a magazine,
they're clothes are gaping open in the
back with like large metal clamps holding
it. I don't care who it is and what's the
best way to pose that's my pose is um,
uh, first to, uh,
you have to let go of any rational
understanding that what you're doing is
ridiculous. And so you have to proceed
as if it's the going very well.
You need to make as many angles
with your body as possible.
It's just like that's how you look
really any kind of
a left.
Like you tried it,
try to look like you took a Benadryl.
That's 30 minutes ago.
There are a lot of tricks,
but most of it is just pretending like
you have to abandon your own sort of
intelligence of like,
this is insane.
Okay.
Well,
your relationship,
it's interesting that you chose
Alec Baldwin and you didn't,
you and Lauren tried to hire
him. He, he initially was,
it was not sure in the,
he sort of said yes and you talk,
what's in the book in an interview
is about your view of him.
Let me just read it.
So I think it's actually worth hearing
everything I learned about real acting,
I learned from watching Alec Baldwin,
I real acting,
I mean an imitation of human behavior
that is both emotionally natural and
mechanically precise enough to us.
It tears are laughing from humans.
He's a master. He can play the
emotion at the core of a scene.
He's falling in love.
His mother is torturing,
his mentor has been reincarnated as a
peacock while reciting long speaks his
word for word, it hitting all
the jokes with the right rhythm.
You like Alec Baldwin,
he's very good at acting.
Yeah, I do like him
and P and a law.
The two of you carry the show as best I
can tell. I, yeah, we're sort of, and,
and the, the, the, the sort of the, the
interaction between the two of you. He,
the, um, just say, uh,
overly self confident
executive and you the very,
very well meaning writer.
Uh,
tell me about, tell me about
how it actually works. Do you,
the stuff is written for you guys.
Do you guys invented funny by himself?
He is funny by himself, but this, the
show is very much a written, it's,
we shoot the show on film
and a lot of um, shows, uh,
are shot on high def video,
but we shoot on film. Um,
we sort of got in under the wire.
Uh,
they don't really let people do that
very much. He works, it's more expensive,
but it's also more kind of,
yeah.
And as you can tell by that,
it's time for another time for another
one of those is Benadryl, those things.
But um,
uh, and so we don't have time to alter
very much during our shooting day.
We shoot about 12, 14
hours a day. And so our,
we have an excellent writing
staff and they write for him.
And we do a table reads of the
scripts about a week before. So, um,
we, you know, read the thing allowed
for a group of about 25 people.
Um, and we, um, and so, you know,
we all have the chance to
kind of respond to the script.
Then a phallic has any thoughts.
Then he gives them a,
we do a rewrite of it and then by the,
by the time we're rehearsing
and shooting on the floor,
things are pretty much locked down.
Every now and then you do find
something fun in the moment.
That is that thing I'm talking about
Harvard and humanity coming to meet.
Um, it's sometimes you, you have to,
you know, the, the Harvard brain,
I still let them be like, okay, these,
these humans think they've didn't
found something in the moment.
We'll let them do it.
Yeah.
MMM.
And uh, and that's sort of how it
goes. So then we rehearsed and then we,
and leave.
Yeah. B. I wanted to talk a little
bit about, you know, you were,
you were sort of pretty famous and then
the Sarah Pailin maneuver came along and
what really happened was she became a
national Canada and people began to notice
a resemblance.
And for a six week period,
you were number one topic in
a national media of America.
Let's talk about how that felt.
Yeah,
it was very weird.
I went from being what I would
describe as kind of comfortably famous,
which was if anyone knew me from
Saturday night live or from 30 rock,
it was because they hadn't really
watched it. And you know, uh, um,
and that, that jump,
uh, of that kind of, uh,
more just arbitrary, um, uh,
fame that it's, it's,
it's very strange. But
when you were originally
opposed to doing it, well, I,
you didn't want her on the show,
right?
I was,
I was talking to Laura about doing it
cause it was this kind of thing where
people just notice that
we had a vague resemblance
and brown hair and glasses.
You know, I saved the, if she,
if Sarah Palin had chosen
contact lenses 10 years ago,
I would not be with you right now.
Cause it was that, that basic glasses,
brown hair thing and people need, people
somehow knew that I had been at SNL.
No one, no one seemed to notice
that I did not work there anymore.
That I had a new program that
was done not for two years and a,
and that even that when I did work there,
I only did the news,
but people were like brown hair
glasses. And we get it, we want it.
And I, but I knew that I,
you know, that was, I had,
I knew people who were real
impressionists, people like
Darrell Hammond and, um,
and in Dana Carvey who really,
this is truly a gift that they have.
And that's why I was reluctant at first.
But then once we ended up doing it,
it was really fun. And then about
six, seven weeks into it, um,
so I wanted to come. Yeah. And I was
again, reluctant because it was, um,
it was, the election was getting sort
of weird and, and there was ugly. Um,
well all of a sudden people are
dealing with you. Yeah. Is that,
did they think you are a
sailor Sarah Pailin, right.
Or they think you hate Sarah Pailin
know and all of a sudden all of the bad
starts to politics come out.
Yeah. And I did find that there was a, um,
there was a weird gender difference
in that people, uh, would,
I would accidentally,
you know,
put on cable news during the day
just to get ready to go to SNL too.
And I would see someone and say, I saw
a guy on there once I'm talking about,
I was like,
he was just thought that I had really
conducted myself badly and she had been so
gracious about this. I was like, I'm
just doing sketches and people, you know,
uh, I think there was a perception
that it was, uh, mean, uh, so,
and some parts of the media because,
um,
and I think that was because it was two
women that that was the only way they
could process it was what was mean.
No one ever thought it was mean of
welfare all to play George Bush.
No one thought it was, you know, mean of
Darrell Hammond to, to play Bill Clinton.
It was a strange difference.
Um,
and she was in fact gracious to
you personally. We had a perfect,
had a nice chat yet we later she said
she complained about your role in her
campaign.
Yeah, she did. Yeah, we had a
perfectly lovely a day together.
And then later in some documentary she
felt that that Katie Kirk and I had, um,
was that I have it a mess,
had it exploited her family
for profit or something.
And I say,
show me the receipt
you
so,
so we're getting ready for,
for the next season of 30 rock and you
also have a movie you're going to work on.
I do. Yes. What's your base side? Okay,
I wonder what that is.
A couple of movies I'm
supposed to be working on.
Okay.
So what does, aside from
from the, the new arrivals,
what does the next few years are? I
assume if Mrs Pailin runs, you'll be,
I hope so. I'm around, you know, it's
tricky for them because I, like I said,
I don't work there, so I,
you know, if some point,
if they want to switch it to an actual,
uh,
SNL employee so they can do it
with the frequency they want,
then I would understand
that. But um, yeah, if I'm,
I'm it would be available for that
in 2012 if they, if they need that.
Yeah.
It's so fun to just go down on us,
you know,
just show up on Saturday and do
one sketch and then start drinking.
Okay.
We have, we have lots of, lots
of questions from, from you all.
Uh, we also, I sent, did
a series of tweets to,
to get questions from people outside
of, outside of Google as well. Let me,
let me throw a few at you. Okay.
And then after a few minutes,
we'll also get some questions here
from folks here in the audience.
We have 47 video conferences going on
in addition to the people in this room.
So we have a lot of people watching.
Um,
this is from, um, Brianna
who's a Googler up.
Who is your favorite guest star on 30
rock favorite posts from your s SNL days?
Why?
Okay. God, there's,
so we've had so many guest stars on
30 rock that we've been so, so lucky.
Um, um, my favorites, I mean we,
there are people that just to meet
them was a dream come true for me.
We had Tim Conway who everyone here,
maybe he's too young to remember who
that is, but um, who, uh, who was on,
he was a favorite of mine.
Um, Jan hooks playing, uh,
Janka Kowalski's dirt bag.
Mother is a favorite of mine because
I grew up watching her lesson.
Al Loving her. Um, uh,
I mean people like Jon Hamm
who just now is like a,
a member of the family and
he's so funny. Yeah. With,
there's like a million of them.
The, um, this is from Jenny also
do, we're given a hilarious,
everyone on the 30 rock cast is what's
the average number of takes that you have
to Redo because everyone is cracking up.
Oh cause everyone's laughing.
Well we do want to take us
because no one knows her lines.
But
I would say actual cracking up happens.
I only like when there's also
a lot of fatigue involved. Um,
Jack Maguire, it gets the, gets
the giggles every now and then. Um,
Alec almost never ever breaks.
Um, Jane Jane. If she's tired,
I would say maybe once a month.
There's the giggles.
Interesting. So this is professionals,
right? Okay. Professor professionals. Um,
this is from a fan of yours and Macedonia.
Okay.
Which is still a country. Uh, Hi Tina.
One of the reasons I love 30 rock so much
has the amazing chemistry between you
and Alec Baldwin. Who Do
you think is, was the actor,
actress you've had the
best chemistry with?
Does it come naturally or
does it require a lot of work?
Oh, that's a good question.
Um, uh, well I think,
I think it probably wouldn't be
Alec Cause we've, I've never,
well I guess at this point I've been on
screen for more minutes and hours than I
was with, with Amy Poehler
or Jimmy Fallon. Um, but, uh,
I think those things come naturally.
I don't think you can take them,
although maybe, maybe he might.
Maybe he, he's good at faking it.
Oh my God.
He's making a bit of,
my favorite scene is the one with
Alec Baldwin where he is, uh,
he's obsessed about meetings and he has
to go to the meeting about meetings. Yes.
Anyone to be on the cover
of meetings magazine.
Gotcha.
My own ambition.
Yeah.
This is from a fan from all Auburn,
Alabama. Hi Tina. Apart from comedy roles,
will we ever see you in some
serious roles in film or television?
Do you also enjoy doing serious or
dramatic roles if you can get them?
Um,
I would,
I would like my career to drift
toward being a judge on law and order.
I feel like
the hours and the outfit appeal.
MMM.
I think it would be fun to do,
but I think,
I don't know that anyone ever let me
do a holy serious role and I'll know.
Yeah. This is from a,
a fan in Michigan. Uh,
thanks for being such an inspiration.
Young women. You're my hero.
If you had one word of advice for aspiring
twentysomething female writers and
entrepreneurs, what would it be? Okay.
Ah, not literally one word now. Now
you're in behaving like a Googler. Yeah.
Uh, so literal. Uh, Gosh, I,
I,
I think my advice would
be to trust your gut,
trust your gut creatively.
Um,
and in any kind of workplace situation
because it's a few times I look back on
anything that I've like, ah, I wish I'd
done this differently. It's what I had a,
a reaction sensor that
I didn't follow up on.
Yeah. That's interesting. Another
question from a fan and Michigan, sorry,
from different one from a fan,
from a Google or her name is z.
You said that you incorporate actual
quotes from your daughter into 30 rock
quote. I want to go there
unquote. Are there other examples?
How old is your daughter?
Ah, she's five and a half now. I was
just, I want to go to, there was, um,
something that Liz Lemon said that she
said when she saw the website for Disney
world.
Awesome.
And I mean your book,
you, you raped activities
with your daughter roughly equal
to everything else you've acquired.
Oh yeah, for sure. I look back, I,
I go through my phone and there's
this weird chunks of time where, uh,
it's like it because I was
like 4,000 pictures on my
phone. Um, and it'll be like,
um, pictures of us like at SNL, um,
doing the Sarah Palin thing and then
I'm taking her to her first day of
Preschool, 25th that and then going
to the Emmy's and there's, you know,
things on the table and then coming back.
The phone is a good way to see what is
actually really doing in your life. Yep.
And we want you to use
a more powerful phone.
Yeah.
And we have a lot of applications that
can help you. Where you going to go?
Do some of them. This is what
we do. We're good at it. Um,
was it, cause I did like that
you could tell it wasn't a house.
Her daughter gets older. You can keep
track of your daughter with your phone.
Trust me, you're going to want our
phones. Subdermal chip you guys. Um,
that's been proposed but we're
not quite there yet. Um, but yes,
I'm trying to think what are the lines.
She's had a thing. She, one time she,
when she sits, she sits like
this when she, she calls this,
I'm sitting on our knees. Yeah.
But until we use that, makes sense.
Tracy Jordan's and talking about his
knees. But I mean it pretty much,
it usually works out very well
for, for Tracy. Jordan's care.
They have a lot of similar interests.
They both get really excited. Benihana
they have to be told they can't
have McDonald's every day.
There's similar people. Uh, this
question is too embarrassing.
I'll let you read it. Okay. This is,
I'm a Googler. Um, I don't know
what these numbers and things are,
but this is it. This is easy.
When it's Eric Schmidt. Get
a guest appearance on 30,
I would say.
Absolutely. I just wanted
to, I just wanted them
prove that I did not submit that question.
So you could have typed this thing.
We will give this. I did not type that
will give this employee a raise, however.
MMM.
Her name is Julie.
Julie. Yes. Uh, this,
uh, absolutely. Uh, in a,
in a universe where our guest
stars have been everyone from, um,
Jack Welch's too. Um, which,
um, you know, Bob Ballard, what?
We tried to get the real Bob Ballard
the explorer, but he was unavailable.
You're just the kind of guest star
that we keep our ratings blow.
Hello?
Yeah. Actually the
question, next question.
This is from a fan in Fresno,
California.
The entire question is pirates
or a Ninja as question mark.
No, I've been asked this question
before recently. I'm not making it up.
Yes. Uh, Chaz and Melton.
Who screening? Um,
I think I said I said pirates the
last time because I think, um, Yup.
Is this strong hierarchy?
I think you're by the water pirates
and I like the outfits better.
Another question. This is a, uh,
from a Googler in 30 rock flashbacks,
you often do depict yourself as a geek
in high school and you're a mean girl
script, identifies more with the uncool
crowd. What's your actual experience?
Is it more sort of comedic value? Did you,
were you sort of geeky where you sorta,
because in the book you describe
yourself as sort of a growing up,
a little bit tentative,
right?
I would say I was sort of Geeky.
I think I also,
I think that almost everyone perceives
themselves as being on the outside in
high school except for no insiders
who kids. Yeah. And those two,
if they don't look that great now, like
when you go back, they peaked at 19.
Um, uh, yeah. And I was, yeah,
it was very revenge with revenge of the
nerds are the nerds is look where we are.
Yeah. It was, it, you know,
AP student on, on the newspaper and in
choir and, and typical overachiever.
Yeah. I mean I was an achiever. I there
were, there were better achievers.
Yeah.
The, um, another question
from a fan in Munich,
Hi Tina.
I know sometimes Google yourself.
No, no, it's, it's exceeded
a level where no really,
no good will come of it.
I think my parents,
we encourage people to use Google.
Yeah.
I use Google a lot,
but I don't Google myself
because inevitably it terrible,
terrible things come up. And I've
tried to explain to my parents too,
they've had,
I think they have a Google alert on my
name and that's not a good thing for
parents.
Wait Til your child does
it. Oh, what's mommy up to?
Yeah, it's, yeah, me and John Goslin.
That's what we're worried about.
Yeah.
Uh,
a question from a fan and Mexico,
what high tech gadgets do you use?
Um, uh, not so many. It's about
my husband. She has her, I mean,
I use an iPhone and an iPad.
Is that bad? That's what I use.
Do you guys make it,
come on guys.
We have lots of Google
services on these products.
Yeah, I have. Yeah. I have
Google products on there.
Um, and uh, computers,
cute
to write scripts. Okay. And um,
that's about it.
We're going to have fit you a
little bit better now that you're,
now that you've visited, visited
Google, another question from a Googler,
you know, and you've got,
you're going to be a nerd.
You might as well have all the right
gear. Yeah. Right? Yes, that's true.
In any advice for new or want
to be sketch comedy writers?
Yes. I'm I a say go to, uh,
either Chicago, New York or
Los Angeles if you can. I mean,
you can find a lot of improv
comedy and other cities now,
but I would just say try to get to a,
an upright citizens brigade
theater to take class if you can.
And in New York or Los Angeles or an
Improv Olympic Theater in Chicago,
second city and just to, um,
do it as much as you can do it,
you know, five, six nights a week if you,
if you do believe a lot of this can
be taught, Improv can be taught,
the writing can be taught. The
comedy. Comedy is both an art as a,
as well as the science.
Yeah, the basic rules can be taught,
but I have tight improv. At second city,
I used to be a teacher there and you
can teach the rules a certain point and
then then about six months in it's,
there's a,
there's people who can truly,
who truly fit that kind of
work and people who don't.
It's true of a lot of things.
Correct. Why don't we get some folks,
we have some folks here on the
questions, so go ahead. Yes ma'am.
Um, Hi Tina. Hi. Actually,
my question follows nicely
to the last one we just had.
Um, I was wondering if, um,
I kind of assume that from that first
day that you took a class at second city
to maybe like that first
day when you started at SNL.
Imagine that was a bit of a long road,
probably full of a lot of fun,
but also a lot of challenges.
And I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about that experience and
maybe share any advice for somebody
who wants to go down a similar road.
Um,
I started class,
I moved to Chicago in 1992 on
Halloween of Knights 92 and,
um, started class at January. And
it was, it was a very fun road.
It was cult-like. The improv world
is, it's all encompassing. Uh,
like I said, we would go take cla.
You all you did was take class,
try to get on stage, watch other
people on stage. I mean, I think, uh,
immersing yourself in it like
that is good. Um, and I do
look back on things that,
um,
I took it all so seriously,
even though it was nonsense
kind of business. Um,
I took it all very seriously.
I remember my boyfriend at the time
who's now my husband, he was, um,
he was the piano player at the theater.
And I was like,
I think we should keep it a secret that
we're dating because I think it'll look
affect the team and people will feel
it. And that's like an impromptu, like,
we're now married for 10 years.
I think we should tell them, no.
MMM.
But just find people who are as intuit
as you are and just do it as much as
possible. Um, things that were,
it did seem like a big deal at the time.
Ah, now I can barely remember, you know,
sort of the politics within the,
the touring company of whose
piece is going to get in. I mean,
all that stuff that seems super serious
now. It is serious in the moment,
but we'll also get easier
as you go. Um, but yeah,
anything with comedy I think just have to,
you have to get in front of an audience
as often as you can because it's the
only way to know if you're doing it right.
We would prefer you stay
as a Google employee.
We have an office in
Chicago, so very good.
Yes ma'am. Um, so my friend
Robin, she's like moved out to la.
She's an aspiring TV slash movie
screen writer, so it's not me. Okay.
But basically I was just curious what
differences there are in the process for
writing for Tds, like say 30 rock
versus writing for movies? Like I say,
like mean girls.
Um, well, uh, let's see. I've only
written the one movie of my own,
so I have sort of limited experience.
But um, with TV the differences,
I think you could come into it and try
to get a job as a staff writer and learn
that way with movies.
You're gonna maybe be writing scripts
on Spec. You're going to be try to,
you know, be a load a lot more. I think
it's a TV is a great training ground.
If you can even even break
in as a writer's assistant
as a great job to have as
the person in the room who is taking
all the notes constantly all day,
you really can learn a lot
doing that. We have some, uh,
we have had two writer's assistants who
now our staff writer, one at 30 rock,
Tracey Wigfield and uh,
uh,
another guy who's Andrew guests
who writes for the Shul community.
And so that is a really great way to,
to learn TV writing and movies.
It's,
I think it's so tricky to break in.
Um,
cause I, I don't even know
screenwriting. I don't know.
I was only able to get into it because
of Lorne Michaels and having come from
Saranac live, I get into it
through television. I don't,
I guess you could write and try to make
your own short films and build up that
way would be the way to to,
but that's going to,
you're not that you're gonna have to
give your friends money and stuff.
Go ahead.
Thank you for being the Gilda
Radner of our generation.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
The world to us.
I agree.
So I have a couple of quick questions
for you. One is what's your best joke?
Cause I want to steal it. Um, number two,
what nickname does Tracy Morgan
use for you? And number three,
I'm a fortune teller told me that John
Stewart was going to retire from the
daily show in 2020 and that
you were going to take over.
So what are your thoughts on that?
Okay.
Fortune Teller told you that? Yes. Yes.
Um, in 2012, uh, I think
nine years. Nine years.
Thank you.
Um,
I think I'll be in nine years.
It will,
I think it should be illegal for a
woman my age to be on television.
MMM.
Uh,
what was the second question?
Um,
Tracy Morgan.
Oh, Jason Morgan. He calls me
Tfa. Most of the TFA. Yeah.
He doesn't have as many nicknames
for me as he has for a, Oh, he's,
sometimes he calls me, this is one
here. You'll see fair. You know,
you're the isis in the hood.
I don't know what that means.
I know, I know, I know. Thank you.
Okay.
And the, and you asked him, he lived,
it was my best joke in terms of something
that was actually on TV or something
or something I use.
Is that something I could
use to make people laugh?
Um, my honestly, uh, my favorite
Joe, just a handy everyday jokes.
Just put a little chocolate on your teeth
and act like you don't know. Is there
good.
Hi there, Tina. Um, I know this,
this season in 30 rock was the first time
where you've actually been able to do
a live show.
And from my understanding that was a
huge accomplishment and a real challenge
for the show to be able to do.
Um,
my question is what other barriers are
you hoping to break with 30 rock or what
are your,
like some of your upcoming on dreams that
you're hoping to achieve with the show?
Um, uh, that's a good question. Yeah,
we did the live show this year was,
was a very exciting and challenging. We
did it, it was to, it was too, right.
We did two, we did one for the east
coast and one for the west coast and um,
and it was really,
really fun to do because it was a,
we did it in studio h where
Saturday night live has done it.
So it was a blending of the 30 rock
crew at the SNL crew and it was, um, uh,
and it was really challenging technically
because with SNL you have 90 minutes
and all these,
um,
kind of built in structures to the show
to get for the show to come in at the
right time. They have, you know,
when you see the band playing does
pop band bumpers, different things,
commercial parodies, things they can can
use to control the timing of the show.
And we had about 22 minutes cause they
gave us a little extra time and um,
it was much,
that was the biggest challenge was like
would we get through the show before the,
before the office just started,
right.
Middle of the shot.
That was kind of thrilling. Um, we,
and we did another thing we did
this year that was a format changes.
We did one episode, um,
called the queen of Jordan,
which was set entirely in a reality show.
Yes.
You went to that,
that can not get it.
That was Tracy. We filled it used to
be right into the system. See, um,
brought that up and uh, I'm trying to
think what else would I think, you know,
people sometimes ask if we ever
would do like a musical episode,
which I think we certainly,
uh, would be fun to do.
But other people have done that. I don't
know. Uh, yeah. Claymation I don't know.
The queer community did claymation
and co I would like to do a,
what I keep referring to it as a Bugsy
Malone episode, which is, um, uh,
has all movie before everyone here was
born where it was a gang gangster movie.
You remember this movie? Oh, the young
Jodie foster it and it was all children.
I would like to maybe do an episode
where all our character just played by
children.
Well, my suggestion, my suggestion
is have a, have a real Christmas
party and invite all of us join your
real Christmas party. I tell him is yeah.
Okay, go ahead. First of
all, thanks for coming in.
30 rock is one of my favorite
shows on television. I think. Uh,
there was an episode last season where
I just laugh for 15 minutes after the
show was over and I literally had,
couldn't stop to breathe.
I think that was when Tracey was going,
it's going on about the dogs
running the Wendy's. But uh, but uh,
but actual question was,
uh,
you also had an episode where you
provided some much needed closure to night
court.
And as somebody who's an,
and I was wondering if there are any
other sitcoms that you've picked for the
80s to, to sort of provide
that sort of culture for,
I know it's difficult to plug it
in, but, uh, and uh, if you, uh,
obviously that might
have been one shot thing,
but if you couldn't answer that
then sort of like growing up,
did you watch a lot of television
and you know, does that,
it seems like that you're
reading the writing on 30 rock.
It seems like you were also a TV fan.
Maybe that's not true,
but I was wondering if you
could have it on how that is.
No, I'm speaking to you think TV
fan growing up. Um, no court chairs.
I mean Mary Tyler Moore and Calvin, all
those things when I was younger. Um, yeah,
I mean I think we are,
our staff has a generation of people
who really grew up on half hour comedy.
Um, good and bad. You
know, there's the, uh,
cause there's this sort of who's the boss
saved by the bell era that I had full
house. I've seen, I've seen a
lot of full house and never,
never on purpose.
I had a, um, had a summer job
once it, a summer theater where we would
go work in the costume shop all day.
And then my roommate and I had like 45
minutes to go home before going back to
be dressers in the show.
And we would go home every day from one
of the only thing, almost full house.
We wash it and we watched it every day.
Um,
uh, but yeah. Uh, is there any TV show
or other show that you would like us to,
to, uh, try to have on?
Ooh, that's tough. I mean, a
teen teen, which was also a thing to
think of one that really raw, satisfying,
ending. Like, you know,
I always felt that the new heart people
thought it was more funny. I Dunno. Like,
uh,
no.
Uh, well let's go to our
next question. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi Tina. My name is Kevin
and uh, my question is,
I recently watched Panio and I noticed
that you were one of the voice actors in
that movie. Yeah. How did
you get into voice acting?
Um, well I was asked to,
to we voice Ponyo um,
cause I would say it was in
Japanese at first and um,
I was really excited to do it because I
think that kind of stuff is really cool
and fun to do. And it was,
uh, I've since, uh, done, uh,
just one other one that was from, from
scratch. It's very different. This mega,
my movie did it from scratch. Do you go
into your kind of improvising and j dog?
But the funny and sort of challenging
thing with Panio was that the animation is
done and use. You have to, and they've,
they think too, it would just sink to the,
to the lip flap as they call it. And
also there were a lot of, um, fun, uh,
this sort of nonverbal things
in Japanese where we, you know,
in English with something of us,
we wake, we'll mix. Huh. Huh.
Or just, you know, just weird
little nonverbals in Japanese.
Wow.
What kind of a, um, an
English language nonverbal.
Excellent.
Next question.
Hey Tina, we're also excited you're
here. Um, my question is in your book,
you get through your list of different
writers for 30 rock and your kind of
favorite singers from each one of them.
So what's your favorite one you were
and was it or not the Subar line?
Cause that's my favorite.
Which,
which was the smile when Alec Baldwin is
talking about all the New York royalty,
the Rockefeller's,
Carnegie's,
all the, all the important New
York families will be there.
The Rockefellers were the Subar.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's not mine.
The one I actually meant to, I forgot
to give myself one in the, in the book.
And I was,
I had,
I had checked on the one that I was
going to give myself and confirmed with,
you know,
cause sometimes you wouldn't make you
very much make sure that it was a joke
that you wrote. And um, uh,
the one I was going to give myself
what I forgot was in season one when I,
I asked you Alec, um, why
are you wearing a Tuxedo?
And he says it's after six.
What am I a farmer?
That's my favorite one.
Love the caricature of senior executives.
Yes.
Hi.
Um, I'm actually really curious
about your life as a parent, um,
especially because you're a mother of a
daughter and I'm wondering with all the
messages of princesses and, yeah. Um,
damsels in distress and whatnot, um,
you know,
you would think having Tina Fey is,
her mom might make being
intelligent and funny. Cool.
But you know what I know about kids
that isn't always the case, can still
be, you know, pressured and, and just
soak it all up. So being five and a half,
you know, looking at your
daughter and how that's going. Um,
what are your thoughts
on parenting daughters?
Well, a silver, my, my, my, my
take on the princess thing was, um,
uh,
and I wonder if I would be the same way
if I had a son and he just really wanted
guns cause my ticket, the princess is
like, you know, I'm not going to fight it.
I'm going to, let's, we can have these
princess toys we can talk about and, uh,
and then it'll,
it'll kind of,
but if I get my son and I gave him as
many guns as my daughter has a princess
dolls,
I would be arrested,
not in Arizona. Um, but I
do try to quite a question.
We play with all the printers and then
we got into this when she was smaller,
this real rhythm of she would always
want to play barbies and say, and this,
we're going to play barbies.
And it's too,
and the game that she coined was two
girls fighting over the prince and they
both want to marry the prince.
And they,
and they said it was this game with
these two barbies, sabotage each other.
Allison was this natural.
And I would try to question it as we play.
I would say like, well, why did
they want to marry the prince?
They don't have to Meredith. And
she'd be like, you're wrecking it.
You know? So I'm just hoping if I don't
force it to stop, it'll go away on its own
18 and thanks for coming today.
Um,
everything's been very
thought provoking for me.
I went to Harvard but grew up in Chicago.
So having a little bit,
right. You're pulling
identities. I'm wearing flannel,
but gophers, so something,
something, something. Think
about a question for you though,
is what's inspiring you now?
Like what are you reading?
Um, what am I reading now?
I just, uh, I finished, um,
I don't get to read for
pleasure very often.
So I finished a seed Martins
novel about the art world,
which I enjoyed very much an object of
beauty and I just bought at the airport,
but I haven't started yet. Um,
Anne Lamott's latest novel. Um,
and I'm reading a lot of baby name books.
Google has an name suggested you.
You do?
I mean in baby girl baby names.
Oh, I've done that. Yeah,
I've typed, yeah, there's a lot of traces.
Yes.
Hi Tina. Um, I represent the human
side of the employees that work here,
so maybe not the Harvard side.
Um,
I went to a university called Salisbury
and people confuse it with, um,
chicken fried steak university. So, um,
I have this run Robin and,
uh, the same friend. Yeah,
she works in La and she, it's a, she
works at a tech company. Okay. Um,
and she, uh, Eh,
it's probably more of like
self deprecating in terms
of like her personality and
Robin,
uh,
is concerned with how that's perceived
in the workplace and how to balance that
and actually getting respect from her,
from her coworkers.
So I know that that's a,
a personality trait that you have as well,
but you are so successful.
So did you have any advice for Robin?
Um, for Robin? Robin is a mess by the way
to problems
is that Robin has, um, uh, um,
but she's asked for help. Yeah, that's
good. That's the first step. I think it's,
you know, willing to have a
self deprecating personality,
but you don't want to be self deprecating
about your work abilities, you know,
and I,
in the book I talk a little bit about,
one of the rules of Improv that we is,
uh, is to make statements as opposed to,
uh, ask questions, which an
Improv is just, you know,
if I say like, who are you,
why are you here?
What should we do?
Now that I'm putting all the
burden on on you, my partner,
and I say that sometimes also
applies to two women, even just with,
with our voices in the workplace to speak
confidently and to try to avoid that
kind of like, I have an idea and I
think for like we were, I'm just like,
I don't know if it's a good idea just to,
just to make statements as much as
you can, but I think it's, um, yeah,
two too
to try to prevent yourself from prefacing,
we work with any kind of apology.
You know, I'm, I have friends,
like I have a friend who's writing a
pilot right now and I have another friend
who was going to be working with her
and I said, well here's a, her deal.
She is going to s this is her routine.
She'll say for 30 seconds. Like,
I don't know. I don't think,
I think it's really stinks.
And then you said you just have to let
her say that and then she does know and
shit doesn't stink. And it's getting, so
you know, if you can, if you can see that,
if you have that behavior in
yourself and you can just kind of,
okay,
skip that part. You know, if you can
just kind of fast forward the, uh,
the pre apology part.
Sometimes I think,
I do think like sometimes what would a
man do in any given situation and they
don't,
they don't apologize so much.
Sorry. Apologize. Yes ma'am. Hey,
we have this group be the last
question. So go ahead. I'm stealing it.
The mic here. I'm feeling shorter
than usual, which is awesome. Um,
so I'm a young mother myself
and uh, for me, you know,
the work life balance struggle hit
me a lot harder than I anticipated.
And I think that's a common experience
across parenthood in general.
And would love to hear your experience
from the, from the comedy world and, uh,
the Hollywood world about how your life
changed after having kids and how you've
structured your time to find that balance,
if that's okay.
Oh, possible. Um, well I think the,
the biggest change is that your,
your priorities just shifted in that you,
you want to go home.
And in some ways I think it makes you
a better employee because I was more
efficient. You're more efficient and you,
I would have spent a lot of time at SNL,
you know, before I was married just to
have hanging out in people's offices and,
and some of that is valuable
to the creative process,
but you don't need nearly as much
as you think. Um, and so that's the,
the thing is you just, you're just
managing your time better. You,
you're going home as soon as
you can, as soon as you can. Um,
and I think, uh, someone was asking me
about this recently, I was saying there,
do you,
I don't know if he find this to be true,
but there's sometimes there's a um,
oh,
we have a reluctance to really admit the
specific details that you may not even
be like, it's hard. But
when people say like, wait,
but what time where you really like,
what time do you leave and what time
did you get back? And you're like,
don't worry about it. It's because you
feel like people are gonna judge you.
Um, and I, I don't,
I think it's probably better if you know,
for us to be honest with each other.
But it is tricky sometimes
to, to say like, yeah, these
weren't very long hours. Um,
and I just, you don't do much else. Right.
You just kind of do your work and, and,
and, and go home to see your kid. That's
kind of it. Then you realize like, well,
I haven't seen a movie and like four years
except your own,
right. Since I've been made to go
to a premiere of one that I, yeah.
Then I worked on. Um, but it's, it,
and also the thing that I find that people
don't tell you is that the amount of
kind of energy that goes into the
relationship you have with your child's
caregiver, whoever that is. That
was one where I was like, oh yeah,
this is a person. This, this is a
relationship. It's approximately,
you get it right then. And that
needs this relationship, uh,
takes a lot of kind of time and energy.
And that was one thing that now I
feel like I've gotten better at it.
When you're first doing it,
you feel kind of trapped by that.
Um, so that will, I don't
know how old your child is,
but that does get a little better.
Go ahead.
Hi, I'm, Hi Tina. Thank you so much for
coming. It's hard not to talk to screen.
Tina.
You're so big,
Huh?
All right. Um, so as a person who is
such a big fan of TV all your life,
you've probably seen shows that have
wonderful actors and great concept,
but horrible writing, like bleeding. Um,
and said that not me. I said
that. Yeah, I know. Yeah.
And so as a writer,
I was wondering if there's a TV show in
either recent history or that's going on
right now that you feel like maybe if
I took this on, this would be, Huh?
Oh, did, I would, could
fix it if you could.
Um, I, uh, no, I think, um,
no. I thought you were going
to ask me what TV shows.
I thought were well written cause I
was getting ready to answer that it was
going to say the Larry Sanders show.
And um,
I think mad men is really well written.
Um, I hear, I don't get to watch it.
I hear breaking bad is unbelievably
grab is phenomenal. Yeah.
I haven't actually seen
it. Yes. Yes ma'am. Hi.
I just wanted to see if you
have any similarities to
Liz lemon cause I love her.
Oh, I do, I do it. What do you think?
I do have a lot of similar as I feel
like Liz Lemon is, if I sort of, uh,
I would say it's a sliding kind of version
of me. If I had stayed kind of, um,
in the way I was when I first was head
writer at SNL and was throwing myself
entirely into that job.
Um, but I have a, uh,
a different home life than she does,
which is very different.
And sad thing is people always
say like, you know, she justice,
why is she so suddenly and you,
you let us be so ugly or they have kid.
And I was like,
she dresses so much better than I would
go if I were going to to 30 rock to
actually write for a day.
Like was the wait Liz lemon
is dressed as how I would be,
like if I was like trying to pull it
together to go to a friend's house for
dinner.
So we're pretty similar.
Hi, you mentioned a Tim Conway who I'm
old enough to remember seeing in the Carol
Burnett show and I was a kid and it made
me think that one of the funniest bits
that I remember seeing in comedy in
general was when he interacted with Harvey
Korman and they would crack in the
middle and they would start laughing.
And it was, it was an in
the moment amount of, uh,
type of comedy that is
obviously lacking from TV. Uh,
I suppose you experienced that in
Improv and SNL was sketch comedy.
How is it making the transition
to television where you
edit those scenes out?
Yeah, well those were,
I mean those things,
the Carol Burnett show was in
front of a live studio audience.
And so there is a kind of immediacy and
that does happen every now and then, uh,
it will happen on Saturday
night live. Um, and it is,
there's nothing more satisfying if you,
there was a sketch when I was there called
Debbie Downer that if I didn't write,
I love it. I did write it, but it was
really funny. Right. And they, um,
they all genuinely truly broke,
uh,
and laughed in it. And it's one of the
most joyful things you could ever watch.
And the thing for comedy
people as you've just,
if it happens once in a while
and it's real, it's okay,
but you never want to be that person
who's kind of like faking it a little bit.
Um,
and we had,
so that's what you don't see it on
shows like 30 rock because there's no
audience there.
So it would,
I think it would seem pretty self
indulgent if we left it just like us.
Thank you. What I, what I
like about Tina is you see,
and the arc of her life so far,
someone,
someone who really has started
off with an exceptional talent,
which she won't admit,
but used it and used it and
was disciplined in the way
she approached everything.
And she had her book.
She talks about the confusion
of where to go and what to do,
but ultimately she found a path that
has resulted now in the second week of
number one book in the United States,
which is pretty amazing for,
I think at first, uh, first
[inaudible].
If you think about
writer, comedy writer,
creator, producer, actress,
now movie star mother,
and she's managed to merge it all
together and produce just an extraordinary
outcome. I can only imagine
what your next decade will be,
and I'm looking forward to watching it
to thank you. And thank you so much for
[inaudible].